much for coming along I'm amazed someday
I am there's so many people out in
London I haven't seen that for many
years before I do start I do want to say
thank you to the organizers of this
session they don't have to do it but
they do it and it's great you know we
can all get together and talk about data
and machine learning and AI and an open
source and that's really cool so I
wanted to not forget the organizers so
this session and we're just going to do
a gentle introduction to neural networks
it's really aimed at anyone who doesn't
know what they are how they work or
perhaps has a little bit of an
understanding but just wants a bit of a
refresher so if you're already an expert
this probably isn't the talk for you and
I won't be offended if you're going to
go to another talk if you're an expert
you might find some of the pictures
interesting so that's just to make sure
everyone's here for the right reasons
and the reason I do this actually is I
do find technology quite interesting and
fun but I found actually over sort of 20
30 years that it's not very well
explained I mean I did a degree in sort
of physics and computer science and
stuff and I always struggle with this
stuff because once you've got it you
sort of think why don't you just say
that why don't you explain it in a way
that anyone can understand you know you
you go to a Wikipedia page on neural
networks and it's actually not that
accessible so I kind of find it fun to
try and challenge myself to see if I can
explain some this stuff to people who
might be sort of 16 18 20 years old you
know at school let's see if it works I'm
not that your 20 year old so sixteen
girls what we'll do is them I'll get a
screen em right first okay that's better
we'll just talk a little bit about
context of where we are with new
networks today I'll explain some of the
core ideas and we'll use some really
simple nerdy examples but through those
nerdy examples we'll pick up some really
interesting points and really valid
points which which underlie why and how
neural networks work we'll talk a little
bit about doing yourself with
Python I'm not going to talk about
particular libraries I'm going to be
talking about how you might do it
yourself the best way to learn about
something is actually to do it yourself
and it's not that hard actually you're
amazed myself at how simple it actually
is there's a particular challenge that I
had a play with which is to train a
neural network to recognize human
handwriting and most people here will
know it is called the EM mist data
challenge but I found it quite fun and
people can relate to that and at the end
of I'll just have some extra thoughts
around how you might take neural
networks forward if you wanted to and
I'll try I might regret this I'll try a
little live demo where we draw a number
I will see if any oral network
recognizes it I tried it last night it
kind of worked
so let's see so let's start with some
quite a couple of questions just to
really get us into the groove here so I
said to my daughter yesterday who's
seven years old I gave her these two
questions I said here's a photo can you
point out the people in this photo and
she did she even recognized there might
be a person here because there's an arm
and she found that quite easy and I said
she can do addition but I said oh could
you add these numbers up and she
couldn't do that easily she can do that
all but but there's an important point
here because humans find some problems
relatively easy and humans find other
kinds of problems quite hard or boring
or error-prone whereas traditional
approaches to computing can do that you
know the computers came out calculators
which are built to do this stuff but if
you went home and tried to program your
computer to find pictures people in
pictures that won't be quite so easy so
there's something going on there that's
different in human brains in biological
brains the approach to calculating if
that's what we do seems to be different
to you know sort of you know cogs and
wheels kind of spinning and adding up
numbers
so clearly we want to be able to solve
these kinds of problems and that drove
the search for different kinds of
computing different kinds of algorithms
and neural networks kind of fit into
that soft computing space and it's
everywhere now it's really exploded you
know self-driving cars ibm's watson
you'll have heard about google huge
milestone in in playing go which is
quite a difficult game to kind of
computer eyes even your smartphone is
getting really rather good at
understanding what you're saying when
you talk to it and that would have been
sort of you know really the stuff of
fantasy sort of 30 40 50 years ago and
neural networks were involved in
google's
achievement so it's driven a lot of
interest so in this next section i'm
just going to go through some simple
examples and it's just to illustrate
some of the key learning points for
neural networks I hesitated about doing
this because the examples are really
rather trivial but I didn't want an
example to distract from from the key
ideas so essentially what we want to do
is to have some kind of machine a box a
thing and artificial intelligence and we
want to ask you a question and we want
it to give us an answer
and we wanted to think in some way it's
kind of what we do and in computing
terms you know you might recognize
terminology like input/output and
processing calculating remember
computers can only calculate don't
really think in the way humans do always
we don't think they do so it's a debate
about how humans brains really work but
we know computers can only calculate so
let's just imagine that we have a hard
problem it's not really hard but let's
just imagine we have a hard problem
which is to work out the number of miles
given the kilim given kilometers you and
I know that's not really hard but let's
just imagine it is imagine we don't
really know how to solve it so what we
do is we invent a model Harry we rented
a linear model we think we suppose
that miles is kilometres times some
number a linear model we think they're
proportional and we have a parameter
which we try a randomly selected initial
number let's just try it we put 100 in
times point 5 to get 50 out and we knew
that's wrong because when we compare it
to real-life we've got some real
examples of what the answer should be we
say okay that was wrong so that's not
great there's an error there so let's
refine that parameter and do it again
well that's better maybe what we've got
inside the circle is now approaching a
proper solution to this hard problem
let's try it again
70 that's gone too far that's much worse
let's go back again and just increment
that little parameter a little bit
that's the best answer yet you know the
error is much smaller so yes that's an
audience trated there is the idea of
imagining how are we imagining a model
of how something could work with some
adjustable parameters and trying it and
changing those parameters based on the
error and that's an important idea for
how neural networks work so it's a
simple idea let's jump to the garden and
imagine we're school kids and we've
collected some bugs and we've measured
their length and width and we found that
we've got two clusters got caterpillars
and ladybirds
they're sort of shorter and rounder
these are long and thin sort of width
and length these are the ladyboys those
caterpillars and if you go back to the
first example where we had a linear
model it's essentially as it's it's it's
it's a straight line one fact one
variable is related to another in a
linear way so maybe we can use that
model that idea of a linear predictor
linear classifier
to help us recognize whether something
is a caterpillar or a worm well that
doesn't work because if something on
this side of the line is supposed to be
a cat a ladybird it's got some wrong so
we'll do that we'll do the same protein
we will adjust a parameter we'll adjust
the slope and hopefully this time it'll
be better but it wasn't we've gone too
far
and that's a much this third attempt is
a much better separating line so what
we've done here if we did that with a
you know a parameter equation we would
have a machine a little classifier which
would successfully identify caterpillars
from ladybirds so when we had an unknown
bug and we arrived at this line through
some examples before we'd say yep we
know what that is it's it's wide and
it's short and long that's a ladybird so
that's how that's essentially how little
classifies work they they partition the
space or variables I guess length width
or something else and if something falls
into one category you say that's that's
an object of a certain type and so on
again that's a simple idea but again
it's essential to how neural networks
actually work so what I skipped over
there was actually learning from data
you train your neural networks with
examples from real-life examples which
you know to be true so here's some
examples here just to I mean most in
real life you had to have training data
sets which are large enough to be
meaningful but we're keeping the
examples simple here so imagine we've
got two examples we've got something
which is wide and short and something
else which is thin and long and we know
that that's a ladybird in a caterpillar
because the teacher told us or the
textbook told us
so we we've created we had an initial
line we just choose it randomly the the
slope of it and we know that's not good
separated because it doesn't correctly
classify those two bugs so we want to
actually shift that line up and if we do
that after the first example we say it's
got to be on the other side of that one
okay that kind of works better it does
actually do the separation let's look at
the second example and we want it to be
we want this to be separated from that
and we remove the line up there and
that's essentially the process of
training that you go through if you're
interested in the maths of how you do
that you can look it up it's not that
difficult there's there's what there's
what you what your classifier came out
with the actual output what it should be
are there's an error a difference and
just simple manipulation of of that
algebra you can work out how much you
need to change the slope by a few if
you're not sure about don't worry the
idea is simply that we're changing that
parameter to better reflect the data
that's the training data but hang on
something wrong there what we've done is
we've looked at each example and only
consider that when we wanted to update
the line
so essentially you know we might have
hundred examples but the line that we
end up with only is is only considering
the very last example so the first
example we moved just over there the
last example we moved over here and that
means you've disregarded 99 data samples
if you had a hundred so that's not very
good so an approach to that is to
actually be less enthusiastic about
updating your slope you moderate your
learning with a learning factor so your
change in slope has a factor in
to call a learning rate and that's
useful because you you over a training
exercise you do take into account all
the data rather than just the last data
point and also protects you against data
which is bonkers at war is is an outlier
or is an error and if we do that we find
that with a learning rate of 1/2 say we
only jump half the amount that we want
we would have you end up with a much
better line so moderating is good and
that's that idea is used in neural
networks to help smooth the learning
that the neural network does and avoid
being drawn towards data training data
which might be wrong there is another
benefit which we'll come to a little
later another example to think about in
real life a lot of data that we might be
collecting and looking at has a
mechanism a causal process behind it if
the thumb is out today my body
temperature goes up or if there's a lot
of light in London the number of people
smiling goes up there's a link there and
sometimes there's more than one factor
involved so you have something
absolutely or something awesome think so
some people recognize that as as boolean
relationships you know if I've been fed
and I've had a drink then I'm happy if
I've not had either they're not so if
data did have that kind of process
underlying it we should be able to learn
we should be able to train a classifier
to going to pick that out and in the
picture we had before it's ok to have
more than one input you have many inputs
that's ok and we don't have to go far
from that a simple linear classifier
picture we had before
I've plotted here zeros meaning false
one meaning true people are familiar
with that and I've colored green meaning
the outcome is positive or or negative
if it's red so if it's and it's only
true if both inputs are true with the or
I've a positive outcome if any of the
inputs are positive and you can see that
a linear classifier a line can
successfully divide those two categories
and what that tells us is that that
simple classifier can learn to classify
data which has this kind of mechanism
underneath it hang in there there's an
important point here but if the data has
a different mechanism underneath it like
an XOR which means the outcome is only
positive if one but not both of the
inputs is positive then actually it
seems that a simple linear classifier
and line can't separate the two
successfully this one doesn't work
because as there's a red there try
different combinations you won't work
and this led people to get very
pessimistic about the potential for
there's little simple linear classifiers
until someone realized that actually the
solution is to have more than one of
them and you can see here that actually
if you have multiple lines you're able
to divide up your data space pretty much
as you wish so combinations of those
simple classifies suddenly becomes very
powerful and allows you to learn to
classify much more complicated data so
that gives us a pointer to the idea of
connecting those nodes heading towards
this idea of neural networks networks of
connected
nodes which on their own do very simple
things let's pause on that for a bit and
step away and move to looking at nature
because Nature has evolved over a long
time to do some things really well and
we talked about human brains earlier
they're really rather good in natural
brains the unit of computation appears
to be something called a neuron and it
takes inputs and passes them along and
pushes them at the other end to other
neurons that appears to be the basic
unit of of a biological brain and
they're made up of many of these and
it's amazing actually we've got
computers out there which have got
terabytes and terabytes of memory and
running at how many thousands of cycles
a second and vast amounts of storage the
huge and yet a pigeon with a brain of
point four grams can fly can feed itself
can navigate can communicate maybe play
it can do some quite sophisticated
things in such a small brain if you look
at a particular kind of worm there's a
link to where all this informations come
from
it's got they know roughly 300 neurons
and yet it can do some quite
sophisticated things we think we're
clever humans of 20 billion roughly
Neera neurons in our brain and nervous
system there are there are kinds of
dolphins with 37 billion neurons
so maybe we're not giving them credit
where it's due
but but it's the important point here is
why why is it that these relatively
simple brains can do things that we
think are quite sophisticated quite
difficult to implement with these kinds
of computers and it goes to back to
pointer right at the start the method of
computing is different and this puzzle
was one of the factors
in searching for different kinds of
computing biological inspired computing
to see if we could get computers to be
more artificially intelligent and again
neural networks are partly inspired by
how we observed brains in nature to work
and going back to that basic unit what
it does it fires if the input signals go
above a certain threshold so you can
feel it a signal and it won't fire you
turn at the dial and it pings on that's
the mechanism at play so we could do
that with our little nodes our little
neuron we could have a step function
where we increase the input and then
suddenly pop it goes on we could have a
different kind of smoother function
where we turn up the input and it
gradually turns on the output that's
quite popular and it's called the
logistic function there's a formula for
it it's popular for several reasons the
maths is quite simple when you play with
it and we believe that nature doesn't
really work in hard sharp ways but works
in much softer gradual ways so there's a
bunch of neurons connected to each other
you can see signals flowing through and
each of those units again going back to
our picture let's start we have lots of
inputs we sum them we add them up and
then with the answer we say okay do we
fire the neuron or not so we apply a
function which might be the step
function or that smoother logistic
function that we pop out the output
that's what a new node in a network is
doing and actually to this day that's
what nodes in in your neural networks do
they might vary the kinds of function
they apply but that's what they're doing
they're collecting whatever is popped
into them and popping out an output so a
neural network finally each of those
units is what we've described it takes
inputs and pops out an output this one
does the same that won't is the same
and they're all connected to each other
in nature they might not be connected to
each other but in in when we program
this stuff it's just simple enough to
make sure that they're all connected to
each other so you can see here inputs
feeding into a network and the signals
then propagate through into an output
and you can relate this back to the very
naughty example at the start of
kilometers and miles we pop in a
question we do some calculation and we
have an answer out and we hope it's a
good answer and if not we train it so
that's pause on that for a little bit
because my brains not like a computer
gets tired
okay let's carry on so where does the
learning happen in a neural network
that's a really interesting and
important point with a very simple
example we had at the start what we
refined was a slope of that function
that separating line the thing that
turned kilometres into miles what's the
equivalent here well there's lots of
places you could do it it may be the
function that turns the inputs into a
node into an output the threshold
function maybe you could play with that
and alter that as we train the network
could do that maybe we could turn some
of these off that's an idea another idea
is to associate a weight a strength to
each of these connections so that the
signal that pops out of one has some
kind of weighting applied to it to turn
it up or to turn it down before it pops
onto the next one and that's that that's
that's valid you know I guess some of
the other approaches are valid but
that's that's the one that's become this
approaches the one that's become really
prevalent so each of these links has a
weight if it was zero
effectively it's cutting the link
because any signal popping out of here
is multiplied by zero it doesn't go in
there if it's multiplied by two it's
doubled if it's multiplied by 0.1 its
reduced
and when we train when we say we've got
an output is not quite right we want to
change something in the network to try
and improve the output
we're fiddling and twiddling with with
those those weights actually there's
another important point that I did skip
over and it's worth going back to
natural brains are really resilient to
damage you can you can chop out bits of
our nervous system and our brain and we
function quite well until the damage is
really quite severe so we can continue
to function even with some some damage
we can actually recover and adjust the
way our wiring works and repurpose some
of the wiring
we're also and the way our brains work
is really quite resilient to bad input
so if the input is damaged you know if I
see someone's face but some of its
missing or blurred or someone's in the
way we still recognize as a face and
that that's that's quite a powerful
thing to see if we can replicate in real
computers and you can imagine here that
actually the learnings spread and
distributed it's not one small thing
that's doing the learning which means
that if I damaged some of this it can
carry on working or if the inputs not
quite perfect that's okay you can sort
of see a parallel there so feeding the
signals forward but just with some
numbers just to be really clear how
these things work just got another
example here of zero and point five a
one and point five simplified neural
network we've got a weight here of 0.9
you can imagine ones popping in and
multiplied by 0.9 so what goes into here
is point nine that's point two so you
can imagine one times point two goes
into here and actually 0.8 of 0.5 also
goes into here so you're summing them up
before you apply another threshold
function you don't apply a threshold
function to the input layer that's just
convention
and you can work that example through I
won't do it now
but that's that's it it's really simple
what's actually happening inside a
neural network there yeah yeah sure yeah
maybe I missed that but why is it
several input so each node is is
automatically collecting different input
or could it also be that several nodes
collect the same input but do different
things with them how does that work and
that's a very good question it's just
convention so you could have one node
with lots of inputs but you would lose
the opportunity to treat different
variables differently so you might have
width height color something else if you
put them all into one node you'd lose
the opportunity to treat them
differently so here we've kept them
separate we might have two variables
width and height you might have many
more and by not putting them all into
one node we retain the ability to treat
each one differently but you could also
have the case of using let's say three
input nodes for the same input
absolutely so and then you can do more
differentiated things on this one input
or is it not yes yeah you could do that
so you are you saying that I could have
one input and then do more things with
it well and then you you I mean here you
have two inputs the one and a half yeah
and then maybe you have several layers
afterwards but could you also have the
case where you have where you take these
two inputs and have let's say six first
layer six first nodes in this first
layer you could do that yes of course
yeah you could you could do that yeah
now that's a really important point
you've jumped ahead to where always
where as going but you're absolutely
right you can have many more nodes with
only two inputs you can have one with
more you can have ten and 100 and middle
layer nodes you could do that and the
benefit of that is that you're able to
learn much more sophisticated models
whereas if you only had one or two nodes
you can see that there is a constraint a
limit I'll come back and talk about that
that is a good point if you wrote out
what happens at each node in terms of
not numbers but but variables I guess
what you would recognize is that what's
happening can be written as a matrix
multiplication so going back
what's popped into here is input one
times this weight and plus input two
times that weight and if I if I had a
bigger example even with a bigger
network
I would I would quickly realize that the
input into a node is can be written as a
matrix multiplication of the weights and
the incoming signals and that you might
think so what you might think are man
matrices so boring hadn't if I'm at
school but actually computers some
programming languages are really good
and really efficient at doing matrix
calculations so we'll keep that in our
back pocket because you can imagine if
if this grows to hundreds of nodes
that's a lot of instructions to write
out you know you can say that is that
Plus that Plus that was that times I
that would be quite inefficient for us
to write out a nationally efficient for
a computer to to process but if we could
summarize that as a matrix
multiplication and it's a programming
language or your library and know sort
of numpy was optimized for doing matrix
multiplications it means that you could
do that very quickly otherwise you'd
have quite a lot of computation it also
means you don't have to worry anymore
about what the shape of that neural
network is you know if it's five by four
or 100 by 200 we just write a simpler
expression
so let's go back to that point about
learning based on the error going right
back that start with the example of the
kilometers and the miles and the error
that popped out at the end we use that
error to inform how we adjusted the
parameter the slope of that line the
same idea applies here we we might have
a neural network we pop in some inputs
we have an output and we compare it to a
training example and we say it's not
quite right what do we do with that
error particularly as we now have many
many places where we could apply to
we've got lots of links that we could
update do we split it in half if we've
got two nodes we could do that that's
that's probably an OK way of doing it
what you definitely don't want to do is
to say the error only applies to this
link and we just leave that as it as it
is so this is where actually there isn't
probably a very good answer but there's
a heuristic approach and splitting it is
one approach another approach is to
split the error in proportion to the
incoming weights so I've got an error
there's three weight and a 1 weight so
we can say 3/4 of it goes there and 1/4
goes there if that weight if the way to
recall then we would split it equally so
that's an approach it's a heuristic and
but it actually seems to work and you
can see here that for internal nodes the
Associated error is the proportion of
this error following that link and the
proportion of this error following that
link then added up again that's just
illustrated with some numbers I won't do
that right now but again that
calculation of splitting the error and
recombining it at internal nodes can be
written as a matrix multiplication and
that's really great because we have the
opportunity to really efficiently do
those calculations with Python and numpy
so actually once we've got that error
what what do we how do we use it it's
it's no longer a linear classifier in
linear kind of function that we're
working with so the algebra is a lot
more complicated this horrible thing
here is the output of an output node as
a function of all the weights inside is
a three by three M Network that's
horrible
trying to play with that probably won't
be fun and it isn't so we'll try a
different approach and this different
approach was one of the reasons why
neural networks we surged an interest
because people felt actually that
training neural networks was was
difficult before some bright spark had
this next idea so we'll take a bit of a
diversion so we've got this horrible
function this horrible mathematical
function and it's got high values and
low values so you can imagine it's a bit
of a landscape high values would be at
the top of the hill you might have
crevices and lumps and bumps we we've
said that it's so difficult this
function to analyze algebraically to
work out you know to do anything really
with it if we wanted to let's say find a
minimum of this horrible function as to
say how would we do that well if you
were on a real landscape and it's dark
which means you can't see the whole
function it's kind of difficult to to
kind of work with it globally what you
might do is to switch on your torch and
look around your feet and see where the
gradient was pointing so you could work
your way down by following the slope
nearest to you that's an approach called
gradient descent I've chosen really
simple mathematical functions here just
to kind of quadratic something's squared
but to illustrate the point
yes we could use algebra to work out
where that minimum is but we won't do
that here what we'll do is use this
gradient descent idea to say we pick a
point we've start a starting point and
we want to get to the minimum well
what's the gradient doing here
well it's pointing downwards so we'll
take a step down I could do it again and
again and if you're on the other side
say whether this slope is pointing up
we'd kind of go in the direction where
the slope was downwards and you can see
that that would work yes it's not a
mathematically analytically precise way
of doing it but when these functions are
hopelessly complicated and you couldn't
do them in a hitter in an algebraic way
this kind of this approach is practice
practical as pragmatic and in many cases
you would get you to the bottom of that
curve what is that what is that
interesting well the error of a neural
network that's we saw that horrible
expression that's going to be a
complicated landscape and we want to
minimize the error so we want to go down
the error function so we want to take
steps to a point where the error is
minimized if the error is minimized is
probably the best that we're going to
get the network to perform cool actually
let's let's look at that diagram again
this is simplified because it's only got
say two weights Illustrated but with a
real network you would have many many
weights inside the inside that network
and they would all contribute to that
error function this is just
3-dimensional covering many many
dimensions and you can do some calculus
to reduce the error which difference
between the desired output and the
actual output we square it actually and
makes it makes things a bit simpler and
order it here but school level calculus
just a chain rule and you can end up
with a function which gives you the
gradient so it says the error changes
with the weights in this way and that's
that's not so hard once we've got that
expression we change the weights the old
weight is adjusted to a new weight by
following the opposite direction of that
slope and we've not forgotten the
learning rate so if we wanted to do this
ourselves that was that was a
theoretical kind of background there
wasn't that hard was it really if we
wanted to do this ourselves a Python
again it's not that hard you can imagine
that we might have a class an object
class and really we only need three
functions an initialization function
which sets the size how many nodes how
many layers even you can have many more
layers than just two or three we want to
train the network so we feed it examples
and we tell what the right answer should
be so you can use the error the
difference to update its weight and we
want to once it's trained we want to be
able to question and query that Network
on on data that we're really interested
in it doesn't actually much more
complicated than that and actually it's
probably a good point to mention that
pythons really good for this it's as you
all know Python is really easy to learn
nice language for the human mind to
going to get into and there's some
really nice libraries which most people
in this conference know and love numpy
if you didn't know it was really rich
it's got lots and lots of them
mathematical array functions in there
and it's what we use for matrix
multiplication there's other cool
functions inside this library plotting
visualization if you're working with
images and I should you know for me I
started with Python back in 1998 when we
had Python 1.5 I think it was and the
numeric library and I left it for a few
years came back and found this notebook
really really great because it makes
working with Python and doing
experiments
really easy without messing around with
source code files and all that in
tidiness it's great for introducing
Python to beginners so the that that
looks horrible but it isn't really
that's the initialized function where
we're setting the number of nodes we're
initializing the weights and you might
say well what do we initialize them with
well random numbers we started that very
first example with the the kilometers
and miles example with a random initial
slope we're doing the same thing here
we're randomly picking what those await
should be actually it turns out that if
you constrain that randomness to a
particular range you're learning works
better so some people will have that
range between minus 1 plus 1 you can be
more sophisticated than that if you want
to won't do the training function just
yet because it's a bit more complicated
with a query function which is really
simple takes takes your inputs applies
that matrix calculation that we saw
earlier the inputs multiplied by the
weights numpy dot is the is a magic
function and we do that again for the
next we apply the activation function
which we told pythor lu is going to be
that logistic one do it again for next
layer and that's your output it's just a
few lines of code and that's that's
taking your inputs propagated them
through the network and pop them at the
other end you can probably reduce that
land to three lines two lines if you
really want to be concise by the point
here is it's not that complicated so the
training function looks a bit more
complicated but really isn't because
what you're doing is pushing them
signals through the network just like
querying but this time we're using the
error the difference between the targets
you know the training example and what
it actually produced and using that
using the other matrix operation that we
saw earlier to refine the weight inside
and that's it that that you know there's
lots of writing there they in essence
there's not a lot to it
all this stuff is on github if you want
to have a play there's people who can
code better than I can so you might
learn better from their code but it's on
there if you want to have a look so now
I'm running slightly out of time so I'm
going to speed up a little bit the the
challenge that I kind of played with was
the very very popular very famous
handwritten numbers challenge all the
emulous data set it's got sixty thousand
training examples and ten thousand test
examples so what that means is you train
your neural networks or some other
algorithm that you've thought of on
those 60,000 and then you test it on a
different set of data this 10,000 and
because everyone's using that one that
set of data you can compare how well
your network or your algorithm works
with somebody else's and people publish
their results on the web if I look at
them the data here's one record and what
it is it's a number at the start says 5
here and then lots more numbers let's
let's see what that actually does what
that actually is that first one is the
label it's saying this is the number 5
someone's written a number 5 and the
rest of the pixel values there's 784
pixel values 28 by 28 if I plot them
using Apple Lib you can see that's a
kind of a 5 because he's not perfect but
that's the challenge how do you get a
computer to recognize even imperfectly
written numbers so these these numbers
of our input to our neural network which
I have an input layer with talk with 784
nodes 7 and 84 input signals we have to
think a little bit about what we want
the output to be we could have probably
two nodes on the output and have them be
binary in a representing zeros and ones
to count up two together for maybe three
then but I didn't do that I just had 10
output nodes representing the numbers 0
to 9 those labels so for example if if
all the outputs were quite small except
one it would mean the network thought
the input was a number five a hundred
and five similarly if that one was high
and all the rest were small that would
mean the input was a zero but this is an
interesting one
because there's quite a big signal here
suggesting the what it saw was a nine
but that's not so tiny either so maybe
four nine maybe it was in doubt maybe it
could be that so that's kind of an
interesting thing to keep in mind so you
can play you can experiment you can
change the number of nodes in and then
in there middle layer of a network you
can you can change the learning rate you
can have a play with that you can even
repeat your training on that data set
more than once to give it a second
chance in a third chance some people
call that epochs and you can see the
performance as a result of that that
change so the hidden nodes if you
increase the hidden nodes you can see
the capacity for learning goes up and
indeed it does but the benefits kind of
tail off of it a massive learning rate
degrades performance and you can see why
that might happen if you're trying to
get to the bottom of a well you're kind
of overstepping it all the time if it's
too small you never really get there
your learning steps are too small if you
increase your number of epochs how many
times you go through that training data
you can see that your results improve
and haven't really understood why they
go down after a long time
but I've left this point in because it's
an important one for us to understand
training neural networks is a random
process you're starting with a random
set of initial parameters so sometimes
it will go wonky so if you're doing this
in real life you've got to run these
things many times and take an average or
take the best because it's random you
might be unlucky and you might have a
bad set of starting points and you might
end up somewhere which gives you a bad
results that's that's the reason why I
kept that data point in when I first did
this with some really simple code using
no more fancy ideas than what we had and
what we've talked about I think I got
something like 80% accuracy
on that 10,000 training set that's not
bad actually for just the simple ideas
no fancy optimizations no more fancy
maths than what we've talked about and
super simple code this gives up to sort
of ninety-six percent accuracy that's
not bad that's kind of competing almost
with or professionals do you can get
better than that that's not bad just
another idea to be applied is if you
think about the training data and you
think it's written by humans what you
might do is to say I'm going to create
new data from that data by rotating it
so go an original and I rotate it a bit
that way and a bit that way to create
more data and see the effect of that and
actually the performance jumped up to
98% accuracy
that's not bad so you can you can you
can do that
I think someone the other day said in a
talk you spend a lot of time in data
science understanding and playing with
your data and not so much actually
pressing go on the algorithm and this
kind of illustrates that point and if
you understand what the data is
you understand that actually it's
written numbers by humans who might
write in some angle so what if we played
with that a little bit maybe that
generates a richer data set to learn
from I'm running out of time but this is
a little something I do want to show you
many people do neural networks by
training them feeding a question popping
out an answer but wouldn't it be
interesting if we did it backwards if we
had a trained neural network we had an
answer
and worked it backwards to see what it
thought the question should be let's see
what happens so here are the numbers 0
to 9 pushed backwards through that
neural network whoa
is that some kind of x-ray over of a in
mind I don't know but actually if you
think about it it starts to make sense
so if that's the 0 and there's dark bits
and light bits what it's telling you is
that if the original digits had ink
marks in this black space it was likely
to be a zero combined with the
additional factor of
the white bit as in there wasn't a mark
in the white bit so you can see how
that's starting to make sense let's take
another example of a three so you can
see that there's almost like it's
reshape there and there's definitely
excluded bits so if they were marketing
as if glutamates that evidence would
probably count against that being a
three and so on so that's that's
interesting sometimes to to do many
people don't do that at it don't know
why there's some link tree to kind of
have a look at and I do this in more
depth with their little kind of ebook if
you're interested but let's try a little
live example and for me this is really
satisfying because it proved to me that
this wasn't I kind of a cooked up thing
if I get my password right cool so I'm
going to think of a number think of a
number give me a number so we're not
clicking it
what's that three okay
let's try three
and I'll resize the image to 20 by 20 a
hi this works and I'll save that and
then I have a network trained and I'm
going to previously as a four and it got
that right right moment of truth
three yep network says it's three whew
so it really does work
thank you very much
Thank You TOEIC we have time for a
couple of questions they don't know this
stuff anyway
so you can train a neural network to
recognize digits so let's say you wanted
to recognize lots of different things
not just digits but maybe words and
maybe objects and maybe other things how
do you do that so you have to really
think about encoding and understanding
your data so if it's words you might
think about what's the best way of
matching what goes through a neural
network and your data so with the images
that was relatively easy mapping we have
pixel values with words the challenge is
to think well how do I get from the
letters of that word to something I
could push through a neural network and
as many ways of doing that you might
have numbers associated with words like
banana raised five Queen is 7 or you
might have you might break it down into
numbers so I don't know because I'm not
an expert but what I'm telling you is
that actually the challenge is doing the
hard proprietary work of understanding
your source data which in your case
might be words and and seeing how that
might map usefully to what flows through
a neural network
there's another question sure maybe you
can give us some more insights on if you
want to do this with a larger image yeah
so is it always that you do it on a
pixel level and then you you now had
just zero and once probably right
because all right I can white how do you
then deal with color I mean it becomes
very big very quickly and it does become
very big very quickly and you can have
much pickup images clearly you can have
color and if you wanted to take account
of that color in your rural network you
have to make sure that you're not you
are bringing those signals into the
network so yes you'd have a much bigger
network
you'd have inputs which maybe took the
red-green-blue components it makes the
learning harder or a bigger task so you
might have to train for longer so
there's always a balance between too
many variables on too many degrees of
freedom and and a chance to actually
learn something useful so the answer is
yes you could do all that you can have
much bigger networks you could take into
account color you could have in a
transparency values and you can have you
can even have features that you've
invented to feed into a network if you
wanted to
there's nothing stop you from doing that
my example is deliberately simple and
usually you should definitely do that I
guess my response is that the more
variables are the more degrees of
freedom you have and you sometimes can
reduce your chances of learning
something useful if you do you have we
had that discussion
two days ago do you have any insights
how people deal with scaling because you
very nicely drew your three into that
little box right so that it's at the
same scale yeah and typically if you
want to analyze a picture an image you
might have a scale difference of factor
oh yeah how do people deal with it it's
you know um you if you have no alpha you
don't know up front what you're looking
but what scale the object is that you're
looking for and if you want to identify
let's say a dog in a picture yeah it
could be massively different scales
Heidegger absolutely so it's quite
common practice to rescale your images
if you didn't want to do that you still
have to have something common across
your images because you're still
training one neural network so you might
say I'm taking samples from an image or
I'm taking other features from an image
yeah that is really it's totally unclear
you know because yes I can rescale it if
I know what's in it and but then I
already lost the F the impact that I
wanted to achieve so there must be some
I mean what do you use
yeah you should what your questions are
zooming in on why dead science is not so
trivial because it's a lot of the
questions are really understanding the
data so how can I have how can you
compare images of different sizes what
is what is it that I have to make a
judgment about or an experiment about to
see if scaling things the same size
works if pixel values from zero to two
five five or zero to one work better
whether I get rid of color data so you
know if it was me doing it and I'm not
an expert I would experiment to see what
worked but you're asking the right
questions that a data scientist would
ask there's no easy answer to that thank
you all right thanks Cheers